I'm not Welsh with Nick Gillespie and
we're here for ask a libertarian day our
first official question comes from
reasons own movie reviewer Kurt Loder
Kurt asked what should be done about
everything this is a great question it
speaks to a mentality that we hit out
here constantly at reason and elsewhere
where people think that something should
be done by the government about every
problem or every outcome that doesn't
work out my housing price just fell down
we need something to be done about it
what we try to remind people here is
that there are consequences for
government actions many of them
unintended many of them negative and
nasty and they always require pooling
one group of people against another so
in many cases the best thing to be done
about a particular situation in terms of
the government is nothing is get out of
the way let people solve it on their own
and the world would be a freer more
prosperous and more interesting place
yeah the Twitter version of my answer is
less at the top of the pyramid where the
great soul ons and wisdom people live
and more at the bottom where you mean
Matt and everybody else lives we get
along pretty well when we do our own
thing and that's really where the action
should be so less of everything up here
more of everything down here and more
current leader and there will be more of
Kurt Loder everywhere he his reason
movie reviews are going to be syndicated
by creators syndicate so look for him
appearing in a newspaper soon somewhere
near you and asked for Kurt Loder